- I think I need a second.
- Put it in that filter.
- I think I need more. Sorry, one second.
- You still need more?
- I swear I lift weights.
- Slow poke. Let's go.
- So I promise I'm grinding this.
Did I, like, change a setting or something?
- Hey, Sue. It's good to see you on
this Coffee Habit Facebook group.
- Hey, how's it going?
- Good. I can't believe you're here, man.
I'm fangirling out.
- Listen, I need to learn how to
make coffee. So, we all have things
in life we need to get better
at, you know what I'm saying?
- That's awesome.
- The truth is
it's my fiancée who is the coffee
maker in the house. She's teased
me a time or two about the pot
that I make. So, this is perfect.
I need to get better. And I need
to put that right in her face,
if you know what I'm saying.
- When did you first start making
coffee.
- I got into coffee kind of
late-ish. It was probably like
my mid-20s where I was a full
go. Like, every morning. I drink
a cup of coffee probably, like,
two to three hours before every
game. It gives me that caffeine
boost we all need. Usually it's
in the morning for me. It's
later in the afternoon on a game day.
- We're gonna start turning on
that hot water. Grab your beans.
This coffee's straight from
Seattle.
I think we're off to a good
start here. This smells delicious.
Fill that bad boy up.
You're doing a great job, Sue.
- Thanks.
- I'm good with directions.
It's the athlete in me.
Go ahead and start grinding that up.
- This is the hard part, huh?
The 2020 WNBA season, we were in a bubble,
which we affectionately called
the wubble. We were there for
three months, and Megan was with
me. And in order to make it more,
like, homey, we actually went and
got a grinder, kettle. You know,
that was our thing. We were gonna,
like, OK, let's have this, like,
morning ritual where we do
the do and we make the coffee.
And very quickly we learned
that hand grinders are not easy.
And very quickly we ordered an
electric one.
- A little trick that I've learned:
We're gonna add some cinnamon
into our grinding beans. It's not
only gonna give it a little
kick, a little flavor, but it'll
help with your game too
with some antioxidants.
- Well, good to know. Where's this been all my life?
- Helping you on the court too, you know?
- Yeah.
- Giving you a little tip on the court. Maybe?
- I shoulda known this like
15 years ago.
- We want to pour
a little bit in circular motions.
We are opening up that coffee
smell, that aroma.
- It gives it a little sumpin' sumpin'.
Have you ever tried a coffee
nap?
- No.
- You basically have a cup, shut everything
down, lights, the whole thing.
Set your alarm for, like, 20, 30
minutes, and essentially take
a nap. A benefit you get from the
nap, it kind of clears your
brain, if you will. And then,
that's when the caffeine kicks in.
So it's like this, like, dual
boost you get. I've actually
been taking coffee naps for a
while whenever I felt like I
needed that, and I highly
recommend it.
- I'm gonna try that for sure next time.
Midday, before my workout.
- [Laughing] Perfect.
- And then we're gonna
grab that flattened umbrella.
- Perfect description.
- Got your mug?
- My favorite mug.
It's like I literally started
collecting mugs when I was
traveling overseas.
- No way. Me too.
- Yeah, and it's funny because
I have all kinds of, like, funny mugs,
crazy mugs, like geographical mugs,
if you will. Like, I played in Russia
for 10 years. So I have a bunch
that say "Russia" on it. And it's this one
that's my favorite. Just, like,
plain ol' mug. I don't know.
I love it.
It's getting to a point
where we're actually running out
of room. So I've been told I'm
not allowed to purchase anymore
for right now. Which is fine. We
have, we have a good collection
so I can work with that.
- I say we take a little sip.
We taste it. And then we can chug away.
- OK. Cheers.
- Cheers.
What do you think?
- Really good.
- Solid. Get your day going for sure.
- Yeah, it's really good.
- I'm so happy I got to meet you
through Coffee Habit.
- Thank you for your help.
I can't wait to impress people.
I just gotta go get some equipment
and I'll be off and running.
- You can take that one.
That's all yours.
- Awesome. Even better.